[Music]
foreign
python with the python Academy Workshop
tries to keep you engaged in the
learning process over several weeks
this approach helps to reinforce your
understanding and retention of the
material while also allowing you to
interact with experienced instructors
who can provide personal guidance to
help achieve your learning goals the
attractive thing about this Workshop is
that it is a posit Academy course that
means you'll learn by doing a six-week
online apprenticeship with a posit
mentor and several co-apprentices
you'll meet as a group twice a week to
work through a realistic project and to
get feedback on your work
at the first meeting each week you'll
have a chance to just work together and
ask questions with your mentor and your
fellow students at the second meeting
you'll present your work to everyone
else this meeting is not optional but
it's the place where you'll get the
personalized feedback that will help you
become a better data scientist
in between the meetings will give you
interactive tutorials that you can
complete to learn the materials for next
week's part of the project
as the project draws to an end it will
be time for conference we'll see you
there in person during the workshop days
and we'll finish up the project together
I hope to see you there
hi I'm see somebody Curry and
learning with Academy is both fun and
effective
because the courses has spread over a
couple of weeks you never feel like
you're drinking from a fire hose you
have time to truly understand a concept
before moving on to the next but it is
more social than a purely online course
you get to meet the same small group of
students and mentors each week so it's a
more fun and supportive way of learning
python has a thriving community of tools
and packages that can be overwhelming
for beginners at Academy we strive to
simplify the learning process by
providing a more structured and
opinionated approach to learning python
our focus is on teaching Learners how to
think about processing data rather than
just how to write code
this approach requires a longer
engagement period compared to
traditional workshops or provides
Learners with more flexibility to learn
from each other about code approaches
and new packages
as a result Learners can tap into the
python Community with confidence and
continue to build on their data
processing skills
[Music]